it's a monday edition of pft p.m
technically pft a.m we're still off on
nbcsn until next monday so we'll be back
before you know it i can't wait to be
back up i've i've got withdrawal i want
to be back i want to be doing the show
every morning and this is the next best
thing having a chance to talk about the
various issues happening in the nfl i
miss chris though and we'll be back
again in just seven days the big news
obviously
this monday
washington
changing their name
sort of
you know the news came out over the
weekend that the name change was
imminent not an announcement that the
name will eventually change but an
actual change of the name that's what
was expected we got a curve ball from
the franchise on monday morning when the
statement which was plastered with the
current logo and name
announced that the name eventually will
be
retired
at some point down the road when they
actually pick a new name so
you know there was some inconsistent
reporting there'll be a name change as
of monday
no the old name is going to be retired
as of monday the truth ultimately was
nothing has happened by way of changing
the name other than the announcement
that at some point down the road the
name will change frankly it feels like
one last act of defiance by owner daniel
snyder kicking and screaming he goes
into all caps never o'clock when the
name will change i mean let's take a
step back and think about it whatever
you think about the name
whether you think it's perfectly fine
you think it honors native americans
whether you think it needs to be changed
and whether you think it should have
been changed years ago there is
something odd
about acknowledging that the name needs
to go
but still keeping the name
isn't it i'm going to be very interested
to see who in the media continues to use
the name
that the team has essentially admitted
is not an appropriate name and i threw
that out there on twitter and people
like they haven't admitted anything well
yes they have what what what have they
declared victory and retreated they have
given it up the only reason they're
giving it up is because
they are getting pressure from sponsors
to give it up and the reason they're
getting pressure from sponsors to give
it up
is because the name is inappropriate the
name is a dictionary defined racial slur
and in this extended moment of racial
reckoning and awakening in america
this is something that had to happen
it's a no-brainer it had to happen now
why isn't it happening right now it
isn't happening right now because they
don't have a new name ready
one of the reasons they don't have a new
name ready is because they've been
screwing around when it comes to
trademark rights we had a story
yesterday regarding all the squatters
out there who have filed for trademark
protection for names that could become
alternative names for the washington
franchise
and other than an effort to squat on
warriors years ago that according to a
recent report the franchise has
abandoned which means someone else now
holds those rights
there's nothing out there suggesting
that the team has laid any foundation
for trying to get the appropriate
protections for a new name and a new
logo and it's both the name and the logo
that are going away
surely they're going to try to get this
done before training camp opens how
awkward this is to make it clear the
name is going to change but to still
keep the name you've got to accelerate
this effort and my guess is there are
some people in league circles that are
surprised by this development
the way this all got started on saturday
charles robinson was on radio with
clarence hill in dallas and charles said
the name come on macy charles charles
said the name change is imminent and
that teams have been instructed to be
ready to scrub the old name
off of
their websites well if the new name
isn't changing
if the new name is going to remain in
place
until i mean the old name is going to
remain in place until the new name is
selected there's no reason to say any of
that my guess is and it's a somewhat
informed guess
that snyder went a little rogue here
keeping the name
until the new name is selected
regardless it should not take long and i
think if anything
this posture this strange posture that
snyder has tried to assume
will result in even more pressure to
move quickly to get
this done write whatever check you have
to write do whatever you have to do to
get the trademarks for the name that you
have chosen and then move forward i also
thought it was a couple of other things
from the press release first
dan snyder and ron rivera are the two
coming up with the new name i didn't
know ron rivera was an expert in
branding football teams i thought he was
an expert in coaching football teams how
does this responsibility get thrust on
to the head coach of the team who's
never even coached a practice for the
franchise are you kidding me
why is dan snyder using ron rivera in
this capacity i'm not saying ron's not
ultimately equipped to do it
but
he's ultimately not equipped to do it
he's no more equipped to pick a new
brand than i am than any fan is
i i don't get it
now hopefully that's just the posture
they're taking publicly and that behind
the scenes they're working with all the
appropriate experts but i'm not ready to
concede any points when it comes
to this franchise because as we always
say dysfunctional teams do dysfunctional
things and when you look at that
statement that was issued today it is
oozing with dysfunction and take a
closer look at the rattling off of the
various constituents that will be
considered as the team pivots to a new
name sponsors
are listed before fans
sponsors
are listed before fans
feels like a little bit of a subtle
middle finger to
the sponsors for being the ones who have
forced this
and regardless it's happening like
if you're gonna do it just do it
why are you
doing it in kind of a half-assed way
why are you just not ripping the whole
name off and leaving it blank who cares
if there's not a name there nothing's
happening right now training camp
doesn't open until july 28th at the
earliest
get the name selected get rid of the old
name and get a new name in place one
last point and this is something we're
going to be writing about at pft i heard
about this over the weekend and we need
to give credit where credit is due
apparently i'm told per sources the
commissioner
was heavily involved in pushing and
pushing and pushing behind the scenes to
get snyder to do this we always thought
that what would happen is there would be
a group of owners who would go to dan
and basically say it's time
like in the early 70s when the group of
republican politicians went to nixon and
said it's time something like that
but that didn't have to happen no other
owners had to get their hands dirty here
roger goodell fulfilling his duties as
the world's highest paid pin cushion
taking on the responsibility of being
the one who told dan snyder what he
needed to hear so between goodell
from above
and ron rivera from beneath
malachi crunch
timely reference for those of you out
there who grew up in the 70s not so
timely for anyone else but the malachi
crunch results in dan snyder finally
crying uncle and saying that he will do
what he had said in 2013 he would never
do which is change the name look
i'm not trying to gloat over this it's
something that needed to happen it was
the right thing to do it's been the
right thing to do for a long time i'm
glad that it's finally happened i'm not
going to get into the why did it take
you so long to do this they're doing it
i don't like the fact that they're
announcing that they're doing it but not
doing it yet but soon enough
it will be gone
and a new name will be in its place and
we'll see what it is
on monday
the nfl and the nfl players association
continuing their dialogue on the rules
for
football in a pandemic and
there was a little bit of a dust up on
social media on friday when nfl media
tried to characterize it is basically
done
just a few more issues to resolve no not
a few more issues to resolve what they
did was they went through and they
hammered out the easy issues
the big issues still remain big issues
include what will the testing procedures
be will it be daily the players want
testing to be done on a daily basis
the league wants it to be less frequent
and
i was told friday they are soon to be
grappling with an issue of draining the
resources in hot spot cities where the
virus is currently spreading unchecked
how do you ensure
that you get all of your players and
coaches and other necessary staff tested
on a daily basis with a 24-hour minimum
turnaround how do you do that or 24-hour
maximum turnaround how do you do that
when everybody else has to wait five to
seven days to get their results there
will be an appearance of special
treatment there will be an appearance of
of inequality here and it was nfl pa
executive director damora smith who said
back in april look whatever we do we
can't be draining the resources that
would otherwise be available to the
public now in orlando the nba has set up
a system where they're getting all of
their people tested
without putting any strain on the local
resources basically the orlando
residents are getting the same
turnaround
as the nba players are getting the
problem is
the nfl teams are not operating in one
city the nfl teams are spread over 30
cities and you've got hot spots right
now like dallas houston miami
phoenix
la
how do you get 24-hour turnaround for
those teams when they are operating in
locations where there are hundreds of
thousands if not millions of people
living there potentially infected
potentially wanting to be tested how do
you make sure that you're not putting an
undue strain on those resources that is
something the nfl and the nflpa will
have to tackle if they go with everyday
testing and they need to go with
everyday testing you have to have
everyday testing
i thought by the time we got to august
and september
and i think others in positions of power
unlike me in the nfl believed that by
the time we got to august and september
you'd be able to do a quick swab of the
inside of the mouth and within 15 20 30
minutes an hour at most you would know
whether you were positive or negative if
we're looking at 24 hours at best
and you factor in the reality of false
negatives
look
one i i firmly believe the nfl is
determined to go forward with football
season firmly believe it
one of the things that can make it all
collapse like a jenga tower is an
outbreak that happens because somebody
slips through the cracks either with a
false negative or in that 24 hours
between test and result
develops
not necessarily symptoms but is in a
position where they are shedding virus
and they end up on a field practice
field or game field that's the concern
and then the virus spreads now remember
they're banking on this idea that when
they're on a practice field open air or
a very high roof like there is in a dome
stadium
it will be harder to transmit the virus
than it is and it contains space they're
banking on that being the truth
you're gonna have a couple thousand
players who end up being the guinea pigs
in that experiment if we can't ensure
before anyone goes onto a field that
they are definitely negative and i don't
think we're gonna be at a point by july
28 or two months from today when the
first sunday of the season rolls around
where could we can reliably say that
everyone who walks onto a field to play
football will definitely be negative for
the virus issues that need to be
resolved
pre-season
union wants two games no let me try that
again union wants no games
league wants two games union keeps
saying why why are we doing this it
creates additional health risk it puts
players who may not be completely in
shape because they didn't have an off
season program and many of them couldn't
work out the way they wanted to you put
them in a game situation you enhance the
risk of injury and what's the business
reason for this it's not like you're
going to make any money off of the
preseason games anyway why are you doing
this the league wants to have the
opportunity to essentially conduct a
couple of dry runs homing away for each
team
go through the whole procedures do it
once before you're doing it in the
confines of a game that counts but
that's something they need to work out
the opt out protocol who will be able to
choose not to play when will you be able
to make the decision when will you have
to make the decision will you have to
show that you have some legitimate
concern or can you just say you know
what subjectively i just am not
comfortable doing this i'm going to take
the year off those procedures still need
to be worked out procedures for actual
outbreaks in a facility what happens if
there is an outbreak will they shut it
down how long they shut it down who do
you bring in to clean it
everything that needs to be done before
the facility reopens those are all
things that need to be worked out and
then there is just the fairly minor
detail
of economics
will the players give up money this year
will the players give up money next year
how do you deal with the fact that
revenue is going to drop this year and
potentially impact the salary cap in a
negative way come 2021. now the nflpa
reportedly has proposed salary cap
doesn't change this year pay doesn't
change this year
2021 salary cap remains what it is this
year 198.2 million per team and then
whatever the losses are gets spread over
the next nine seasons basically the
remaining nine years of the current
labor deal
through 20 2022-23 that's what the
nflpa would like to do now from the
nfl's perspective
the teams incur the losses now
you're recouping the losses as far out
as 2030
i don't know that they're necessarily
going to go along with that but that's
part of what they're trying to work out
so they can reach an agreement so
everybody comes back and
not just
shows up for work but feels good about
it see i think this is why the nfl is
being cooperative with the players you
don't want to just say these are the
rules
too bad if you don't like them
you want the players to be all in you
want the players to feel confident you
want the players to feel comfortable and
you want the players to be inspired to
do everything they have to do to remain
virus free that's the key and that's
what the league is trying to do because
look if they don't work out a deal here
there's been talk about the players
going on strike or some sort of work
stoppage
we've written about this and i was told
this very clearly on friday
the players will not strike they can't
strike if they strike the concern is the
league will say fine first of all the
strike's in illegal wildcat strikes
second of all we're pulling the plug on
the cba because you have launched an
illegal strike we can kill the entire
labor deal the labor deal that the
league would not give them now remember
back in march when the pandemic started
but there was still that window for the
players to vote in favor of the labor
deal that was on the table my position
then was
take the deal because if you don't that
deal's going away forever they're going
to go back and reconfigure everything
and reconsider everything and
recalculate everything
based upon the changed circumstances
and i guarantee you if the league had a
way to get out of this current labor
deal they
would that's why the players won't
strike what would happen is this
if they reach an impasse on these
procedures for returning to work the
league eventually would say all right
hey we can't reach an agreement these
are the rules we are going to implement
and then it would be for the union to
file a grievance under the labor deal a
non-injury grievance expedited fashion
to get an arbitrator to rule on whether
or not these are reasonable and safe
precautions that the league is taking so
they would use a litigation tool to
basically say to an arbitrator
this doesn't work this isn't good enough
and it'll be for the arbitrator to
decide whether or not it's good enough
the arbitrator bangs the gavel that's
the decision and it's either the rules
change towards something the nflpa is
more comfortable with that the
arbitrator believes is more safe or the
arbitrator says what the league proposes
to do is perfectly fine so that's where
this is going this does not threaten to
derail the season directly
what it threatens to do if there is a
fight between the league and the union
it threatens
to put the players in a mindset where
they're not willing to do everything
they need to do where they're not as
careful as they need to be where they
just don't care as much as they should
about ensuring that there isn't an
outbreak and maybe like in a weird sort
of way rooting for the kind of outbreak
that causes the season to collapse like
we don't want to be doing this anyway
what a shame that would really be a
shame if the season comes crashing down
boy that would be awful if that happened
you don't want the players to have that
mindset you need them to be all in with
the eventual procedures and keep this in
mind
we wrote about this over the weekend i
was astounded when i saw the videos from
the oil mastermind summit in houston or
in dallas either way one of the two
current hotbeds dallas is where they had
it and look i understand they tested the
guys supposedly when they got there and
they had all the things they were gonna
do when you see the videos no social
distancing
not a whole lot of masks and the video
that was just horrifying to me
the hot wing eating contest where the
guys are clustered together i saw one
guy with a mask
even even if you tested all those guys
again you know false negatives we do
they get the results do they really know
everybody's clean are they sure
everybody is negative it's just amazing
to me you know even if you're testing it
doesn't mean it's open season to cluster
these guys together for a hot wing
eating contest and someone pointed out
to me and i think this is a very
accurate observation
it shows that the players ultimately
don't care they're not worried about it
they're going to play they're not going
to opt out for the most part most of
these guys are going to play and they're
not afraid of getting the virus the
worst thing that happens in their mind
is they get a week or two off they don't
have to play football for a game or two
now look plenty of guys don't want to
miss any time whatsoever but these guys
just don't care they do not care and
they should
most of the guys at this oil mastermind
summit have a bmi north of 30. that puts
them at risk
of a
potentially serious outcome if they
develop covet 19. so
look i i think what's going to happen is
football will proceed at the nfl level i
think nfl football is the only football
we're going to have this year when it's
all said and done
and they are going to try their dandis
to make it work and they're going to
have a bunch of replacements ready to go
in the event that there's an outbreak
and the real question is this because i
think they will just be plugging new
guys in like they always do guys get
injured all the time hey somebody's hurt
plug someone in well somebody's on the
covet 19 let's plug someone in all 10
guys are on the cobot 19 list plug
someone in as long as they got warm
bodies to plug in they'll keep doing it
here's the question if someone dies if a
player dies or a coach dies of covet 19
what happens at that point
does it all just shut down or do they
just keep going and think about the
contrast march 11 rudy gobert of the
utah jazz test positive and that shuts
down basketball hockey and baseball in
its tracks and everything else done
this time around they fully expect to
have positive tests
that anywhere from 100 to 250 guys are
going to test positive when they show up
for training camp they expect that they
accept that the question is what happens
if and hopefully it is if not when
someone dies in the nfl family as a
result of the virus will they keep going
or will they pull the plug and i have a
feeling
by the time that would happen
i mean look at how we've just been
gradually desensitized to this whole
thing we're just kind of living with it
we're kind of dealing with it i think if
someone would die they probably just
keep on going remember when corey
stringer died of heat stroke back in
2001 during training camp did they stop
training camps and have an emergency
assessment of appropriate procedures for
practicing in the heat did they do all
that right then i know they did it for
the next year i don't think they
immediately swooped oh i know they
didn't pull the plugs on training camps
now they may have made some adjustments
on the fly but they didn't say we have
to stop everything we're doing one of
our players has died
based upon in part the way we conduct
training camp in this hot humid weather
with large men walking around carrying
all this equipment as we expect them to
to perform in this kind of
irrationally warm environment
uh they just kept going and i have a
feeling that's what'll happen if it
comes down to it a couple of other quick
points before we wrap this up on the
issue of opt-outs
and and i again i don't know how many
players will opt out but there is
an intriguing dynamic to keep an eye on
there's a group of players
who have ultimate opt-out rights
and that group is larger than it usually
is
because the league has not been
aggressive about signing rookie draft
picks
if you don't sign them you don't have to
pay them everybody's been waiting
there's no off season program to put
them at risk
a lot of the rookies have not signed
contracts
and they don't have to
they don't have to do it and you could
have
think about it
and we don't know what these rookies are
thinking a lot of them are thinking i'm
fine i'm healthy i'm not worried about
it but
if the opt-out rights are going to be
restricted for players the rookies have
the ultimate opt out right all the
rookies have to do is not sign their
contracts and you know what if they sit
out the whole year and they don't sign a
contract you know what happens they go
back into the draft
that's a dynamic we have to at least
keep an eye on
i'm not saying anyone's going to do it
i'm not saying anyone should do it my
point is this at a time when the union
and the league are haggling over the
opt-out rights for veteran players who
have contracts
the rookies who don't have contracts
have an easy path
you just don't sign your contract i'm
not signing a contract i'm taking this
year off if i was in college i'd be
taking this year off
right anybody who think about this
anybody who entered early
and skipped that last year of college
they'd be skipping that last year of
college anyway because chances are
there's gonna be no college football
so
i i think you're gonna have some guys
who decide to wait and see how this all
plays out and maybe they won't sign in
time for training camp and maybe they'll
wait to see what it looks like when we
get into early september and maybe you
will have some guys who say you know
what it's in my own personal interest to
just take this year off i'll still make
my money i'll be fine i'll still be a
great player
but it's in my best interest to just not
play football this year and let's see
what happens next year
you can't rule that out and the point is
for the rookies who haven't signed
contracts they have every right to say
we'll see you in 2021 let me know when
the draft is throw my name back into the
hat and we'll see how it all plays out
by wednesday at 4 pm eastern we'll know
whether or not the franchise tag players
have long-term contracts there's also a
transition tag player kenyan drake of
the cardinals
dak press got the big name here no
indication that he and the cowboys are
working their way toward a final
contract remember the cowboys have to
offer him something that gets him to
give up 69.08 million over the next two
years plus that year three who knows
what the cowboys would do 45 million
under the transition tag 54 million
under the franchise tag or let him walk
away and and let him hit the market yeah
if we're not sure what the guy's value
really is let him hit the market
you find out what his value is
maybe you find out the hard way because
somebody else pays him more than you
will
but that may be what happens in 2022
either way
cowboys have to give him something
that will convince him to give up his
right to just say i'm going year to year
i'll take my 31.4 million this year i'll
take my 37.68 million next year and then
year three we'll see what happens
we laid out the numbers last week he's
in a better spot over the next few years
than patrick mahomes is other than the
140 million dollar injury guarantee that
mahomes got under his contract but again
you can go out and buy that insurance
and dak prescott surely has
he's in a great position from a cash
flow standpoint flexibility standpoint
and ultimately ability to become a free
agent by 2023
when mahomes will still have nine years
left under contract with the kansas city
chiefs one last point about franchise
tags
there's a few players who still haven't
signed their tender aj green yannick and
gawkway chris jones
i wonder if the teams are thinking at
all about rescinding the tender
because at this point
who else is going to pay these guys
what they are due to make under the
franchise tag who else is going to give
these guys what they want by way of a
long-term deal right now
i mean maybe chris jones
right maybe somebody says we'll bite the
bullet over the short term to get a
dominant defensive lineman who
potentially could be one of the best
defensive linemen and all of football
will do that
but
think about the bengal situation
they typically don't keep guys who are
franchise tagged beyond their franchise
tag year if this is aj green's last year
in cincinnati or if they may trade him
halfway through the season and they're
looking at the balance sheets and they
realize they're going to lose a ton of
money if you can clear up whatever the
number is 17 million dollars if you can
just make that go away
just by saying oh go ahead aj go be a
free agent first of all good for the
bengals second of all
is aj green going to get that money from
someone else at this point is he really
going to get that kind of money
so just something to think about is this
deadline looms if these guys don't do
long-term deals will teams for the
players who haven't accepted their
franchise tenders
consider rescinding to tender it's
happened three times in the last 20
years jeremiah trotter corey simon and
josh norman
uh i wouldn't rule it out this year
given the the realities of the pandemic
finally before we go i was very
intrigued by the story that came out
over the weekend about the new england
patriots resolving the grievances that
had been filed by antonio brown
and aaron hernandez
to the tune of creating seven million
dollars in cap space this year
and someone smarter than me pointed out
the reality that those grievances got
resolved
after
the cam newton contract became official
and the thinking is
that during the entire camp negotiation
however long it lasted
chances are didn't just come together in
a day or two
that for an extended period of time
newton and the patriots were talking
and the patriots said this is what we
can pay you look at our salary cap it's
not like we can give you anything more
this is all we can do
1.05 million dollar base salary veteran
minimum yeah we'll guarantee half of it
yeah we'll give you 700 000 in per game
roster bonuses yeah we'll work out this
incentive package 5.75 million dollars
that basically requires him to be the
league mvp in the super bowl mvp to get
it
but that's all we can do we just don't
have the cap space
look here's look here here here here's
our we'll be completely transparent
here's where we are we have we don't
have the cap space
and then after the deal is done they
pick up seven million dollars in cap
space look
just to tie the two ends of this edition
of pftpm together
look at how washington is handling
its name change how it's bungling its
way through it and look at what the
patriots did strategically to get cam
newton at the best possible contract
they could
and then
clearing up seven million dollars in cap
space after the ink was dry in his
contract
dysfunctional teams do dysfunctional
things
and functional teams do functional
things
and that may be one of the reasons why
the washington franchise under 20 years
of ownership
by daniel schneider haven't had a whole
lot of success on the football field
maybe this new name whenever it comes
out will be the first step
toward the team turning it around but i
have a feeling as long as snyder's the
owner fans are going to be waiting and
waiting
and waiting some more
for
uh the ability to feel like they did
between 1982 and 1991 when they won
three super bowl championships that's it
for monday's pft pm we'll continue to
monitor and report on all developments
in the national football league at
profootballtalk.com
and we'll do this again tomorrow
everybody have a great day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports